نذهب الان الى الكويت ساره وهاجر معنا من
هناك الخبيرات في لغه الجسد يسعد صباحكم
ساره وهاجر بالاول
ساره وينه هاجر وين
يسعد هالصباح ساره وهاجر اكيد يعني انتم
من ضمن الناس اللي دخلتوا في قصص هاري
وميجا وكل هذه الامور اللي حظيت باهتمام
كثير من الناس في صور اليوم راح نعرضها
امامكم وامام المشاهدين حتى نحلل معكم لغه
الجسد يعني على ماذا تدل لانه دائما لغه
الجسد تدل على كثير وتحمل مع الكثير من
المعالي خلينا نشوف مع بعض الصوره الاولى
ساره وهجر ونقراها مع بعض
طيب خلينا من هون لا يظهر الصور على
الشاشه صار وهاجر اليوم بدنا نحكي بالاول
اذا وحده فيكم كمان تشرح لي اوكي عم نشوف
نحن الصور شايفين معنا الصوره الاولى يعني
الامير هاري وزوجته ميجا ماركل تحت
الشمسيه تحت الشمسيه بلا وعد ساره وهجر
دايما تعبر عن حالتي الاحتواء رومانسيه
[موسيقى]
طب هلا احنا كمان بنشوف الصوره الاولى
خلينا نشوف انه الامير هاري لانه هو شخصيه
الاسبوع خلينا نشوف كمان نقرا ملامحه لغه
جسده نظره العيون على ماذا تدل
الامير هاري دائما يستقيل
يعني هو شخصيا شخصيا تحب الهدوء تبي تبتعد
عن كل البروتوكولات العادات والتقاليد
وتبتعد ايضا عن الاضواء الواضح ان هي اللي
صاحبه فكره انه يسوون الفيلم الوثائق عشان
تتلمع صورتك
حياتي بريطانيا
شعره
ايه هو كان في الصراع نفسي يعني بين
ذكريات وبين اللحظه نفسها بدا يضحك معاها
بدا يتفاعل بس بنفس الوقت عندها ذكريات
تمنعها من انه يتفاعل معها في نوعان ما
نقدر نقول لشعر بالذنب او حاله من التحفظ
بالمشاعر لاحضنها
الدهني اعلى من حضور الامير
شاطره بالتمثيل شاطره
جدا لدرجه اسمها
مثلا ترفعها حواجبها كلمات بالفم كبير
بالفم اثناء الكلام
ضغط عليها بشكل اكبر فلاحظنها شيء بشكل
كبير عند
عكسها راكان هادي اكثر
وخلينا كمان نركز على وجه ميجر بما انه
هلا عم نشوف احنا عاري وميغن يعني شايفين
هاري كيف ونظره وكل هيك حواسه تجاه ميغان
بس تعبير ميجر شو بتحكوا لنا كمان فيها
مثل ما ذكرنا هي وايد فيها رغبه في
التاكيد فيها مبالغه انا عنه
اكثر منك
الحقيقيه من الرجل
طيب اذا كمان قربنا الابتسامه بين هاري
وابتسامه بن ميغان هل لانه الابتسامه
بالعاده هي كلمه بدون حروف وتدل على كثير
من المعاني
كان دائما ابتسامته في غالب الاحيان هي
خجوله نوعا ما على ماذا تدل ايضا
تفسرنا ساعات عاجبه اللي قاعد يصير او
عاجبه
يقول لها الكلام
ما بدها تقول متردده
لما يطلعها لو تلاحظوني
يعني المكان اللي اهمن بلد فيه وهذه
الامور اكيد اتاثر على رغبته بعد اها
وكمان انا يعني لفتله نظري اكثر في كل هذا
الحديث انه صاروا وهاجر توام ورغم انكم
توام يعني والملامح كلها متشابهه ومتطابقه
الا انه حتى طريقه ااه تحليل كمان متشابهه
وفي رغم اختلاف بسيط طيب ساره وهاجر بما
انه الامير هاري هو شخصيه الاسبوع فقط هيك
بس اذا بدنا نعطيه مواصفات وفقا لكل هذه
المشاهد وكل هذه الصور وقراءه تعبير
بكلمات ماذا تقولون عن هاري
شخصيه متمرده
متردده متسرعه
يعني المفروض
انا بشكركم جزيل الشكر من الكويت ساره
وهاجر خبيرات في لغه الجسد يسعد هالصباح
شكرا لكم